et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec benjamin cucq journalistes
automobiles auteurs du livre noir de
renault aux éditions first bonsoir
benjamin cuche merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france l'état qui va
donc garantir ce fameux prêts est ce que
cela peut acter la survie de renault
selon vous ce n'est finalement qu'une
étape
on ne va pas mourir soit arrêtée avec
7,7 idéaux que renault puisse mourir
renault a 120 ans c'est-à-dire 10%
existence même de la france
un peu plus même renault ne va pas
mourir c'est un à la traversée deux ans
de guerre des crises dans un traversé
plein entreprises faut juste qu'elles se
recentre sur son coeur de métier qui est
la voiture deux segments à b et c
voilà au qu'elle arrête dans des délires
de construction plein de types
différents de véhicules ça veut dire que
renault est quand même un petit peu
condamnés à se réinventer en tout cas se
retrouver
oui même temps c'est logique si on
produit les voitures dans un endroit et
qu'on produit moins en moins de voitures
dans un dans un endroit que mais qu'on
produit des pièces dans ce onze pays
c'est à dire la france en france d'une
deux choisi comme usine de co dans ses
vignes de pièces on les produits et pour
des voitures qui sont finalement
assemblée en turquie en roumanie au
maroc ou ailleurs
waouh en slovénie à un moment on
fabrique pas de pièce c'est un peu comme
la sidérurgie
on a toujours produit moins de voitures
en france et en amont c'est plein de la
baisse de la sidérurgie de la production
d'acier
à un moment on produit là on a besoin
des pièces c'est assez cohérent que
renault veut supprimer des usines qui ne
produit sur une pièce qui produisent des
pièces pour des voitures qui sont
fabriquées ailleurs
effectivement ça c'est sur l'aspect
réalité le pragmatisme ses salariés bon
ça c'est moins votre domaine
effectivement c'est le social mais voilà
ces salariés on comprend leur colère et
leur désarroi alors leur colère est
complètement compréhensible
leur colère est complètement con t'es
complètement compréhensible mais je vais
je vais être une fois n'est pas coutume
totalement d'accord avec monsieur
martinez quand il dit qu'il faudrait
faire un procès aux
à l'ancien savary à l'ancien j'ai à dire
c'est varié à l'ancien mandataire social
de l'entreprise c'est-à-dire carlos
ghosn qui est responsable de ce fatras
qui est responsable de tout ça mais
c'est mêlée en même temps on peut aussi
s'interroger sur les anciens dirigeants
je vais les anciens je l'avais déjà dit
et votre compte est le seul ministre de
l'économie qui s'est opposé à carlos
ghosn c'est emmanuel macron avant et
maintenant le manant bruno bruno le
maire en temps en temps un peu imposée
en temps un peu s'imposer vis-à-vis de
la direction de renault et entrant
conditionner les aides aux à
l'intégration au maintien d'emplois
mais avant les dizaines de ministres
qu'on a eu aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche on laissait les clés lui ont
laissé les clefs de la kangoo au
président au président gumbs c'est que
j'allais y venir
mais mes prochaines questions carlos
ghosn ce plan s'est réellement son élite
âge assez totalement son héritage le
plan actuel est totalement les étages de
carlos ghosn c'est carlos ghosn n'avait
pas commis autant de malfaisance dans
l'entreprise
le casse sociale de dos dans
l'organisation même de la destruction de
l'emploi de renault on n'en serait pas
là
j'ai la cjr il avoue il a eu un délire
de vouloir être numéro un du numéro un
de l'automobile mondiale
en agrégeant renault toyota pato contre
toyota en agrégeant renault nissan lada
mais toutes les toutes les marques du
groupe renault nissan en disant on est
numéro 1 mais comme sida 2ème médaille
c'est pas les jo est numéro un de
l'automobile on n'a pas une prime on n'a
pas c'était juste on son délire
mégalomaniaque fait finalement basse et
les ouvriers qu'il paye et les salariés
et les salariés tout largement toute la
production qu'ils payent pas ce qu a pas
eu d y a plus de synergie qui a été mis
aucune synergie n'a été mise en place
rien n'a été réfléchi si lui il était
jusqu à 100 dans son délire et son sa
volonté de gagner beaucoup d'argent sur
le dos sur le dos tout le monde aussi
bien de l'état qui a trouvé hockey parce
que l'état quand il supprime des postes
chez renault qu'est ce qu'ils payent les
chômeurs c'est l'état qu'il était
derrière justement effectivement renault
vous dites voilà c'est une entreprise il
ya 120 ans qui va jamais mourir enfin
c'est une bonne chose que ce
constructeur français vivent sous
perfusion de l'état il ne trouve pas sa
propre aux poteaux nomi pour sortir la
tête de l'eau c'est très français tout
de même voix c'est très français mais en
même temps c'est fait 75 ans grenon vit
sous perfusion de l'état depuis sa
nationalisation renaud vit sous
perfusion de l'état
renault a été nationalisée parce que oui
renault était un collabo du régime nazi
l'histoire est écrite général de gaulle
a décidé de nationaliser renault pour
cette raison le et depuis renault
renault a toujours été toujours été
assez représentatifs de l'état de la
nation
même quand il était encore renault va
bien la france va bien quand la france
voit moins bien renault va moins bien et
vice versa aujourd'hui comment vous
voyez les choses pour cette entreprise
comment vous jugez cette stratégie je
pense qu'elle est je pense dans le
détail déjà faut voir une chose c'est
que le canard enchaîné annonce l
éventualité de cas de fermetures
d'usinés
on en a une seule ce qui est une bonne
chose le président serrar est quelqu'un
de bonne volonté visiblement c'est ce
qu'on appelle un honnête homme
c'est pas c'est pas un type qui obnubilé
par sa gloriole personnelle et c'est
l'argent donc déjà ces deux bons points
après la stratégie va recentrer les
véhicules recentrer les véhicules sur
une gamme qui marche c'est pas une
mauvaise idée
supprimez supprimez les bd culte si peu
monospace de la gamme et augmenter le
nombre de degrés assuré ne peut être que
bénéfices arnaud ne peut être que
bénéfique pour chronogramme aujourd'hui
que peuvent craindre le plus les
salariés à part évidemment ce qui arrive
à ceux de choisy le roi est ce que les
autres doivent craindre une baisse de
salaire pour sauver l'entreprise
non je pense pas je pense pas qu'il
faille craindre une baisse de salaire
pour sauver l'entreprise
pour de multiples raisons à commencer
par la première c'est que les salaires
chez renault dont j'ai à paris carlos
ghosn n'ont jamais été n'ont jamais été
délirant c'est une pierre dreyfus qui
était président historique de renault
avait
avec un salaire de 1 à 12 par rapport au
salaire du plus petit chez renault sa a
été longtemps une pyramide écrasé a
longtemps été la politique salariale de
renault des salaires pas très élevées m
assez bas en bas de l'échelle mais pas
très haut
tout en haut de l'échelle ça ça a été
mis à mis à mal par des médias lomani
carlos ghosn mais globalement on va
c'est difficile de tondre d'autres aura
neuf donc je pense pas que le salaire de
ses ouvriers de ses salariés puissent
être remis en cause
merci benjamin qu'une journaliste
automobile auteurs du livre noir de
renault aux éditions first d'avoir été
avec nous